we are doing Monster Squad we are
talking about nards Menards let's see
the new Dan George's that door like the
last one we did yeah um we're haunted
yeah just so you know showing me not
just losing every okay what's just
better well certain it's a little off
actually man what are you doing okay
that's that's a bathroom just wanted to
sundered OCD um so I yeah we're gonna
tells his wife by the way because that
door she thought you in DC and then
everyone the last video was like Kevin
who was that way give it away boy loose
London everybody was gonna make up a
whole story and well then everybody's
like and to be fair that was the much
scarier than anything in devil worked
okay um but okay we're gonna talking
about master squat I really want to talk
about this movie because I feel like I
love this movie I love it so much but it
shouldn't work in some respects in many
respect it doesn't work it's a kids
movie are you talking what it was just
funny no but that's the thing it's like
okay you can see it we saw it I mean
yeah but they're nuts
I mean mummy to it may be our manner and
kids can't see it no no regular Larry
but you know what I mean I mean this is
a film where it's like there's obviously
these kid tropes like this should be a G
or PG movie but they're scenes where
it's like Dracula's called his little
girl a bitch and they're like shooting
all the gory bloody scenes and stuff
like that uh and they're blackmailing
this girl with like naked pictures of
her which clearly she should be
blackmailing them cuz that's very
illegal um and there's just all these
inappropriate scenes but it's not really
made for adults as clearly kind of made
for that kid audience when do you see
how Dracula looks and frankenstein looks
and stuff of the Frankenstein monster so
it's one of those things where it's like
this shouldn't work in may respect it
doesn't work but it's all in strange way
it does work it does that's why I love
doing the review because it's very much
one of those movies where it's like no I
can't defend it as good but it's awesome
it's just an awesome movie and I think
kind of it rides the that film that
you're not supposed to see as a kid yet
somehow is made for you which I think
they're trying to expose more more now
kind of like Basic Instinct um oh I was
gonna say the transformer movies but you
know I mean that made for you know 13
year old and I can say above but not
really just 13 year old and under
Michaels and Michael Bay ones yeah
I'm honestly a thick monster squads more
adult hell I agree right but but that's
why I'm saying goes kind of like this
you know now we're trying to hit that
crowd a lot you know with kind of that
13 like only that a like 13 to 15 kind
of Oh am I trying to think what in
transformers would even that like I
guess yeah Megan Fox in the car wash but
that stuff like bros before hoes and
stuff like that it is pretty violent a
lot of like the I care about yeah I mean
they're going through Billings they
don't show people falling but it's like
that's the only missing thing you know
like tons of people died he's all out
there flies a little building it's so
innocuous like I can't even like Monster
Squad feels harder core to me than trash
yeah no I agree I feel like it does like
sort of have like the gory miss and like
people will die maybe because it has the
cojones to actually like throw kids in a
situation like that yes at a Shia beef
that is what it means
um but yeah so this is one of those
films where it's like I saw it if I was
to watch it like when it came out which
I kind of did actually was a little kid
um but if I also watch it as an adult I
would be like who is this movie made for
I mean what is it trying to accomplish
you can't show us some fix made for us
and you show my not babies so it's not a
surprise at all that it bombed it didn't
do well uh you know because it was how
can you find an audience for it but now
in mattoon
my nut sure was promoted properly either
because how do you promote this fill how
do you promote a film like that yeah uh
it just it did just there's some classic
movie monsters and even to like kinda I
don't remember cuz we saw in a video hmm
as kids I don't remember ever seeing
trailers for it now we're going oh I
need to see know as much later yeah well
and then you have something like you
know even with transformers as obviously
gearing towards you know thirteen year
olds as that is yeah it's trying to make
the machines look tough look dirty you
know even though CG is not always that
great is trying to look like it's really
there as soon as you see Dracula in that
cave and you see the fake bat flying on
the strings and stuff like that and you
know the very stock werewolf and stock
Frankenstein monster like the old movies
it's like come on this is clearly like
for kids you know get not little kids
but you know kids and you're gonna throw
it all this stuff feels so sort yeah so
these kids and I think it could very
well be maybe that lack of not exactly
knowing the audience or maybe knowing it
too well in a sense ah is kind of what
makes it so interesting but that's okay
because they they balanced all of that
kind of like darkness and grittiness
with you know Holocaust reference yes um
seems like that oh my god
you want depressing go to the guy I mean
and now it's off of League of super
critics but the original comments on
there maybe they're still on there on
our channel was everyone saying well
what I don't get the number of the arm
what's he talking about I just don't get
it just it's like oh my god wait up buck
if you're making the rest of us look
like jerks yeah fuckin but are you gonna
explain it to you especially in this you
know light-hearted video but but it is
got true they'll throw in something like
that in this movie and it's just well
apparently now as we found that it's an
educational film yeah uh you know the
tone is all over the place but in a
weird way that's kind of what's so
likable about it because it shouldn't be
in there but it's also the stuff that I
think thirteen year olds
like to see that kind of makes it
interesting it kind of makes it fun it's
a kids movie doing the things that kids
movies why was that is a perfect age to
watch this is three to fifteen now I
like I think I found when I was like
yeah I exercise I thought was like kind
of meant to be yeah of course when I
grow up I'm it's not the perfect ages
boom is like eight to twelve is like
that perfect age where like it'll hit
you probably just right but yeah any
higher and it's a little it's a little
silly cuz yes classic movie but in any
lower like you saw when you were five
which may would have made me about no
yes wait why did you
I was a always like I could be wrong uh
I want to say no cuz we were here and I
want to say you would have been like six
but I could I would have been eight cuz
I felt like oh this is like the real
dragon of the real Frank Simon who like
these are the legitimately scary one you
were course when I get older it's like
no you see I would have been aid so I
liked it that I I mean it I think maybe
some of it went over your head cuz I'm
not sure I took it seriously seriously
yes yeah and again it had a nice gritty
edge to it I remember enjoying it yeah a
lot like hey I was like this is Ross I
mean when you see the vampire the lady
vampires coming down with the you know
they're getting stabbed in the hard
stuff I was just like oh crap like this
is the real this is the real deal like
this is what I thought like you know for
a kid it is yeah don't like the Keaton
bad news it was like the difference
volition raised out of horror movies yes
it was like the difference between the
60s Batman the Michael Keaton bad males
like oh this is the real bad male like
the Keaton family I thought this was the
real Dracula the real Frankenstein
monster and then of course I grew up I'm
like no the original Dracula is the real
Dracula the original practice guys the
real friends you remember the first time
we saw it
it was that friend's house no okay we
did see it again at a friend sighs do
you remember the first time we saw no
maybe not I we were at a church group
honest to god like they would like yeah
right and I don't think they had any
clue any cool
phoo what the hell I go in the basement
because yeah it was animation you told
it was in it was in the basement a banal
drive-in process that Irish I was like
allowing us they didn't know it was just
in litters like Oh like universal
monster movies like who the hell knew
Plus little kids going after it I mm she
was the 80s it was always a crapshoot
how dark your kids films pg-13 was this
brand-new rating and I doubt they look
they just saw the kids on the cover of
the Dracula monster the Frankenstein oh
oh nobody okay okay I'm sorry
who in the 80s look at the ratings who
looks at the ratings now yeah honestly
but I mean who in the 80s looked at the
ratings if it looked kid-friendly yeah
Kevin had a kid-friendly cover that was
it and I got away with a lot
nobody was looking because you still
pg-13 was fairly a new thing you still
were just boasting the RPG G category
and generally if it look like a kid's
film on the cover you were gonna sit
there and go to where I need to see if
it's pg-13 like no that didn't happen
Angie Lee knows we want men and women
back then that means imaginary boys and
girls but we were boys and um with
cojones and Oh
ovaries of Steel I don't know as I
remember now you know what I thought
this was when I first saw it I thought I
know you remember this but I love you
out there don't know it I thought it was
like a grownup version of the Halloween
that almost wasn't cuz they had all
together and everything it because I've
ever seen
where's the window watching with jokes
about you know what fuck it let's just
say this let's just say this that makes
the movie even more cuz Mel's like one
of my big introductions like trakula and
Franco science stuff was how we almost
wasn't uh we was at the function except
John her is yours if you like yeah look
it's on YouTube you'll see where I'm
coming from because it's all the
monsters come together he'll ask your
crime Evan DS yo kiss 30 minutes goodbye
it's the student of seventies thing for
little kids and it's it's fine for
little kids of watchin godly stoop isn't
one so you YouTube that watch it and
then think of Monster Squad
as the unofficial sequel yeah like the
grown-up
um so that was kind of like you know
dating I think that was like my official
introduction of like what I thought
drank simmering so much and uh straight
yeah so I love you don't know what that
is I mean it's cute for little kids I
mean it's like harmless but it's a Tom
it's so dumb and cheesy um but where
this I think is very harmful to little
kids but also dumb and cheesy but a lot
more fun
Oh marvelous your mind we turn up
fucking fine on even that mindset of you
know movement doesn't have Marg kick
even about wolf man as nerds that's
totally a kid line that defined a
generation totally a kid mindset cos
nokia thinks about their like the
Wolfman having balls and then sudden
it's like I guess he does yeah I mean it
just should concern they should um but
uh yeah I just love this movie I love
the review that we did of it cuz I
really felt like with the reality
monster attacking that is like okay this
really you know as a film it kind of
doesn't work at is cheesy it is
ridiculous but as just this awesome
what the fuck experience it's amazing
and it's so much fun plus chart guy yeah
well chart guy you know that that was
just our key Kia analyst and as a kid I
should do this one have kind of the
geeky kid I'm generally all if you've
string oli these kids films together you
get every trope well and you know no
this one had that one in particular but
other films do well none else thing is
something like stranger things you know
of course is this huge hit a lot of fun
to watch it out now an assault is that
show any good I don't know yeah yeah of
course we see I can't watch it like a
minute it came out i watch that oh let
go my eggo bitch um and yeah but that is
clearly for adults paying homage to some
of these tropes but is clearly this is
an adult show you know uh you know
Goonies is still for kids it has some
adult illness buzz mostly for kids you
know et kind of same thing um you know
we're Monster Squad it's like it's hard
to say who it's for honestly that's kind
of what makes it honestly assigned your
things if you just put more of the kids
in there you could argue is just as much
for cuz I'm trying to think what is so
awful in there that you couldn't show
it's not an awful set there's a lot of
focus on the adult is more focus on
these off like that that's true and
that's the only 40 separate well topic
that's a scary thing in tone when I
think of kids films you know
particularly they're getting better with
getting darker but generally like that
that Dark Age or Disney was doing
direct-to-dvd sequels and like it like
when I think of stranger things I'm like
yeah if you just had the kids in it more
that could have passed for a kid's film
in Haiti
ya know really think about that for a
second oh that's kind of like that's
fucking horrifying even even like our
most a good way but even our like our
most kind of inspirational lovey dovey
light-hearted you know like et is still
a very kind of dark gritty looking
before they replaced the guns with
walkie-talkies yes our kids films are so
dark that the directors themselves had
to try to correct them as yes oh it's
too dark they can't take this sides of
walkie-talkies was that lifeless black
cat is like yeah you know they're saying
that walkie-talkies - where the hell are
gone true oh I just I love the lead you
know what it is I this is I stranger
things I haven't got it right cuz its
aping the eighties kids films and like a
GLC modern consumes I get it right but I
like 80s kids films cuz the kids always
seem real you're not perfect they swear
whatever happened to kids swearing I
missed that anymore I'm terrible like
yeah right he's gonna think I'm some
inhuman monster but I'm just like I
missed it the last movie around I'm
doing that and like you're really
working at feeling natural like for a
kids movie I'd say probably Sandlot is
last I remember there probably are more
don't get me wrong that what was said
let's bring them up I love to know these
kids movies actually have like the kids
swearing and they feel like real kids oh
not to say there's like none I'm sure
there are but that's
although that's one that's coming their
memory I have a recent memory of a long
time ago Christmas story they swear oh
no and I like that I mean they took out
though the f-bomb basically to replace
it with fudge but I mean you knew what
that was
so it's still word have not you work
delightfully in check out I don't need
kids throwing f-bombs everywhere like
it's us but but when you take it out
entirely it doesn't make it realistic me
the portrayals of school and stuff in
most modern movies I don't even
recognize I'm just like I just remember
we were like swearing up a storm on the
playground and like you know and like of
course you don't do that in home in
front of your parents maybe that's the
problem the people who are writing these
are parents and the image of their kids
that they have now are all innocent
because that's what their kids are
showing them again I guess we never
would do it in from our parents because
you know they kill us I so I think it
really does depend on who the movie is
made for I really feel like you know
Sandlot is made for that exact age and
above you know lots also made for kids
who lived through the 60s yeah but I
mean why made for who's made for our
parents or people you know and just uh
but I can see you know a kids movie
where the kids don't swear but it's like
that not who they're going for they're
going for a little younger they're going
for you know a certain demographic and I
get that but yeah there is something I
don't need it's I see the pg-13 orgy
that PG doesn't exist
I don't need Thumbelina to have swearing
in it but you know time see ya know
they're trying to do a realistic
portrayal of like the school grounds or
whatever or what child it is like you
know I just I would also say can a kids
movie yeah but like I said it's that
trying to get rid of peih-gee by making
everything PG and the pg-13 is like the
grand
oh well the heels are transformed as
soon as our kids swearing cuz they can
not because that's how kids a small
satisfy any no well I guess it does
because it's still in their heads yeah
um it's just such odds just such a
cop-out but yeah so that's something I
like to see kind of more of uh you know
and once a story here's the thing - why
say swearing in movies
don't mean like whatever in a Pixar film
or frozen where they sow a swear word to
get the PG rating cuz Oh more people
come see as it is PG when you're seeing
a Pixar film you get this concept that
it really is aimed at all audiences you
should even if they don't understand it
be able to take a three-year-old into a
Pixar film yeah and I have them dropping
you know f-bombs yeah talking about that
but I'm talking about like well Monster
Squad is an example you know stranger
things is an example you know I yeah you
know movies we grew up with explorers
that was an example fighting Christmas
story honestly why the Navigator was a
little more and that was more dignified
but you know um Christmas stories it
yeah like words like what we're trying
to show you realistic representation of
what it's like in childhood and what
some exaggeration early but yeah your
mother's like my kid never swear is I'm
like well no I haven't heard no no no of
course they swear you're the parent
though so you can't just in here it um
yeah because I'm not going to wear
around you or anything as we ever have
kids I'm sure we ever hear them sir how
dare you but harder huh and that's why
we don't have kids
um but but yeah but in whatever they do
on the playground you know with their
own friends you know song has end up
breaking the lawn like that care yeah
we're lighting themselves on fire doing
something really stupid
someone's not doing things we did when
we grew up I want and I think the idea
and like I said I don't necessarily I'm
not necessarily against it is that they
I guess well I think pg-13 isn't always
that great cuz it's sort of normalizing
it to a point where it's like well
there's no reason to get offended at all
there's no and it's like that's not true
either it's like you know there is a
language it's not always bad words or
swear words but there is a language and
a way to talk you know that's
appropriate some places may appropriate
others and I think some movies are
trying to emphasize that to certain age
groups but others are trying to make it
look like it's nothing it's nothing at
all it's like no it is something but
there is we still we saw a monster squad
knowing that we probably kind of
shouldn't and you know we saw aliens
and it kind of probably shouldn't guess
so even though it's like we saw that it
was good
no going in with that on Debbie Does
Dallas thinking we probably should wait
we definitely should I still have scars
from that he Ava's mirror is better than
Catholic High School girls enjoy all
right nothing gets better the Catholic
High School girls in trouble
Sammy Loeb records presents like how
many player you can get the three people
I saw Kentucky Fried movie Rebecca oh my
god um but no I think that is important
that awareness that you shouldn't be
watching it so there is kind of like
there's this inappropriateness but you
still watch it and it's oh you know it's
okay but you have to have that awareness
now this isn't this kind of isn't okay
but you can handle it there's a it
creates this responsibility to the
language need that exposure to something
naughty every once in a while they need
something that they're like ooh like
maybe I'm being bad just seeing that
feeling of like you're getting away with
something or you're in on the adult
thing you know the the swearing or the
smoking of the drink or whatever's going
on the mood that's why I love
Ghostbusters I've been smoking up a
storm in one I saw Batman when I know
okay you know me nine or something like
that and me but you know clearly not 13
yet but I was just like okay I know this
is bad so you feel a little bit more
don't you feel like you have the
responsibility to handle don'ts and
adults need adult things every once a
while I need a hardcore our movie just
to remind me I'm a frickin adult and you
know what it works the opposite way too
sometimes like the past couple months
are a great example the shit hits the
fan and your life is just so fucked up
at the moment that you're just like you
know what I need someone fluffy
I need storix yeah I torch was amazing
by the way fucking stars go see stalkers
I didn't go v-log I just go see it I
need Rick and ho and its torques
I need like a Pixar movie I need
something like fluffy that's not you
know pg-13 or some is so my problem with
pg-13 is it it doesn't satisfy anybody
because you're not getting a real adult
experience
like you would out of an arm movie
you're definitely not getting that
anymore
an elephant sort of kids film it is
literally the Blanding down of both
sides where it's just like well we're
gonna make the kids just feel naughty
enough without anything really like it's
pg-13 movies back in the day we're way
more hardcore than they are now yeah
they're almost are Temple of Doom is
with Brad Brad Jones nails he's like
that's a fucking hard R movie otherwise
a lost art was an arm yeah it was they
cut laid they put fire and for the
Belloc's exploded feelin oh and that
maybe there's a goddamn God somehow
makes it PG let's give a shit what I saw
my business a movie is Roger Rabbit this
so if you're if you're a kid you're not
getting the full on like adult
experience though because look we saw
aliens Holland what we're pretty damn
you ain't yeah well most committed at
least you were six like Gannett scared
the shadow of us that's the point it's
why it's a mustard Oh everyone everyone
needs that moment in their life where
they see something adults and so you
don't get that out of a pg-13 foot but
if you're an adult you know it would be
like pg-13 Deadpool or something you'd
be like what the hell is this or pg-13
Robocop it's like I want the adult thing
why am I getting this watered-down piece
of trash I feel like they maybe are sort
of making a comeback because Deadpool
was of course a gigantic hit and then a
sausage party did pretty good and that
is just totally celebrating being
everything anti PC every stereotype
every offensive thing you can imagine
and it did well that's also because it
was well written the same thing with
Deadpool so I hope there is more effort
going into and don't get me wrong I know
it's also called sausage party so people
would see it just because they were just
like yeah I want to say I saw shot but
they would be satisfied to it will be
sad about the movie but no it's one of
those things where it's like I feel like
we are so middle-of-the-road right now
which is who I am no but with the chart
the chart says you know what I people
want just enough of everything don't
rock the boat
everything goes in peaks and valleys I
think there was a while where we had
nothing but Gees and nothing but ours
and stuff like them then we tried to mix
it up and then now we're in the PG pg-13
age and it's like good we needed that
for a while but now
let's go back let's go to the Gees and
ours again you know let's go to these
extremes and let's make them good let's
make good G films let's make our feel
good our films you know I feel like they
are making good PG films they're just
our good G Phil's are just calling it PG
for no damn reason well I'm okay well
I'm okay with that
PG is a rating doesn't bother me PG says
does game I don't care like velvety I
devil editorial I've you can see it
pg-13 like used to be like this is your
baby step right below in our yeah like
this is your way to get into an r-rated
movie practically like and and now it's
just been watered down to the point it's
like well this is your it's now probably
somewhere what would be in between a PG
and then the old pg-13 yeah like that's
what bothers me I'm like okay then what
is this rating even exist it's just a
slightly harder core version a PG and
that just doesn't interest me I'm like
just give me one or the other
yeah uh can you imagine this film being
made now as a pg-13 we're gonna make a
quote-unquote kind of kids film starring
old movie monsters and it's going to be
rated pg-13 I don't know I can't see it
I think you it's not as not as news no
you would make it as a teen no no not a
kiss no no that's what I'm saying like
you know there's no way you could get
away with this but as past range that
came out even then I guess that is the
time for it to come out don't get me
wrong eighty is where they did kind of
launching the envelope even yeah it was
school having to exist it was yeah is
this so still I think that's why the
film is so fascinating like I said I
mean it is just clearly a kid's film but
there's all this stuff that's clearly
not kid related but kids like to see and
like I said you could argue they kind of
give birth to like Michael Bay pg-13 a
story behind this movie maybe it's got
some convoluted production history and
it was meant to be more monopoly saw
stuff like Goonies and films like that
was like it was like what you can blow
up a little bit it feels how they want
to seize like
that next step and it's sort of took a
little - biggest step that couldn't find
an audience and not understandably so
you know it's very understandable why uh
but that just made all the more
intriguing looking back years later and
watching it so yeah I think there's
definitely going to be a very particular
audience that although there is a very
particular audience I like so like I
said it's coming back and people just
talking about it more and more because
of what a strange anomaly it is uh so
yeah I love it I don't know if I can
defend it as like good cinema not high
art yeah but it's just it's a great time
capsule yeah it's a great time Campbell
what does the strangeness that we grew
up with yeah and it's circa 1982 about
1990 yeah just like the the 80s and the
sort of non PC non appropriateness I
should say not PC but but not
appropriate definitely for like you know
kids feels even down to the rating uh
that just draws us to atiba for 70s was
dingy and like a sort of pot high hmm
then the 80s was more of a critique okay
yeah there's all about the curse
whenever I see that means yes some of
these kids films it's all these like
groovy colors and Farah man and then the
80s is just like gritty sort of like you
just snorted way too much I was it like
in a stranger you can have to kind of
identify decades by a drug you know like
pod coke nineties would probably crack
early two-thousands would be like meth
just kid coming from there yeah little
weird marijuana yeah and maybe some acid
think it's a massive yeah acid
definitely like all I think a willy
wonka like you definitely acid but
there's some about the 80s I'm again I
was the worst yes 80s and 70s kind of
blood but it's I don't know which was 70
so probably more hot and that's six 50s
out that would be Disney that would be
or morphine hi yeah
pink elephants and just cigarettes just
yeah just totally gross Elena granted
cigarettes in your mouth
well that's true pink elephants he was
drunk off his ass yeah no I know yeah
when he was getting off the morphine I
mean that's I'm sure it's where that
came from shirts were half the Disney
stuff came from but I mean the mouse
like and Dumbo got drunk in that yeah
exactly yeah booze and cigarettes 60 70s
it's you get into your acid kind of
marijuana phase and then eighties
nineties coke and crack yeah 2000s all
about Method ectasy yeah it's got weird
we kind of sum up these two decades with
two drugs um
fascinating huh so like an interesting
commentary or documentary on that I
don't know some great writer is gonna do
much more with that than we are um but
yeah so Monster Squad
it just it rocks nards go see it it's so
much fun um yeah I just like peeing
standing up I go see also see you if you
have it yeah she's still she's still
quotes fan all the time that that's one
of my favorite reviews I definitely see
that as well um Monster Squad there is
nothing to not like wolf man's game
nerds art nerds